the screen will show with how Rudnick
Happy Thanksgiving screen junkies want
to see my turkey impression because it's
Thanksgiving and because we already gave
you two honest trailers last week money
remember we're gonna read your most
thankful comments before you judge me
know that I'm reading these for the
first time and you're getting my genuine
reaction I the princess 8550 says the
host meets plastic surgery on his face
before I go and do it to him first I
can't tell if that's a threat or like an
awesome offer are you a surgeon will you
give me a stronger chin are you a girl
yeah cool and Machine Works says what
did you what did you that's the name of
my new sitcom Rudy Vasquez says your
arms are hairy as thanks for noticing
Rudy you know what I got an elementary
school for these imagine this on a kid
Cecina guy says the host sucks ass get
rid of them to see in a guy I've never
sucked an ass but I have done other
things
Travon Cal one says I hated the guy
talking the whole time the most
you're not funny well I may not be funny
but travandkel one you are hilarious and
your family must be so proud to be
related to a homophobic monster via
mentee says subbed for honest trailers
starting to regret it
and this bloke and the comedy he
presents are about as funny as child
leukemia I'll see you at the kids
hospital original masters says I know
the other guys but who's the skinny
Jewish fruit job work II am says this
video is painful to watch my hand is
reaching for the unsubscribe button
there isn't an honest trailer by next
week
hey work young put your other hand
reaching for I should give it a rest
buddy you're gonna sprain something well
now I know if anybody leaves a hateful
comment you're just trying to get on the
show and you love me thanks for watching
I'm Howard Nick Happy Thanksgiving
bye don't forget to watch Twilight
breaking dad's where dad's answer
Twilight trivia for their daughters we
made an 11-year old cry